-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well
tonight,
and now we are going to
get to the news.
Defense officials in Ukraine
have warned that the Kremlin
could be using deepfake videos
to spread misinformation
to Russians.
Okay. I knew Putin didn't have
an Iron Man suit.
[ Laughter ]
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
suggested in a court filing
yesterday that it has evidence
that former President Trump and
his campaign tried to illegally
obstruct Congress' counting of
electoral votes.
Yeah, we know.
[ Laughter ]
Watching the House investigate
this thing is like watching
"The Office"
with your grandmother.
"I think there's a spark
between Jim and that Pam."
"Yeah, Grandma, it's Season 6."
[ Laughter ]
A bipartisan group of
Congressional lawmakers is
calling on President Biden to
ban Russian oil and gas imports
amid the country's invasion
of Ukraine.
The bill has support from
both sides of the aisle
and the aisle.
[ Laughter ]
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
yesterday told several students
standing behind him at an indoor
event that they did not need to
wear face masks and said,
"Honestly, it's not doing
anything and we've got to stop
with this COVID theater."
Although for people who moved
from New York to Florida
during the pandemic, "That's the
only theater they have left."
[ Laughter ]
"Can you believe what they call
bagels down there?"
[ Laughter ]
I'm doing the Gilded Age
New York.
[ Laughter ]
"You call this a subway?"
Authorities in Germany yesterday
reportedly seized
a Russian billionaire's
$600 million mega yacht.
Said the billionaire,
"Oh, no, my backup yacht."
[ Laughter ]
Nike announced this week that
it's temporarily closing
its online store in Russia.
Apparently, it was giving Putin
some bad ideas.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
Luxury brand Bulgari said
this week that its sales
have increased
since the Ukrainian invasion
as wealthy Russians are buying
jewelry amid a collapse
of Russia's currency.
On the plus side, it does make
oligarchs easier to spot.
[ Laughter ]
A crown?
IKEA has announced it will
temporarily pause manufacturing
and retail operations
in Russia and Belarus
due to the invasion of Ukraine,
while IKEA in Ukraine is opening
their doors to Russian soldiers
and hoping they can't find
their way out.
[ Laughter ]
Amazon confirmed yesterday that
it plans to shut down
all of its physical bookstores.
They're getting back to doing
what originally
made them successful --
putting physical bookstores
out of business.
[ Laughter ]
A JetBlue pilot blew twice the
legal limit on a breathalyzer
yesterday after being removed
from the cockpit of a plane.
They were immediately suspicious
since the flight was Delta.
[ Laughter ]
"What are you doing in here?"
"Oh, let's get this puppy
in the air!"
[ Laughter ]
"Where are we headed?!"
Tomorrow is National Sons Day.
Said dads, "What did I get you?
What did I get you?
How about a roof over your head,
wise guy?
What did I give you?"
[ Laughter ]
Really good dad.
And finally, New York governor
Kathy Hochul yesterday unveiled
plans to permanently allow bars
and restaurants to offer
to-go alcoholic drinks.
So say hello to New York City's
newest mascot,
Martini Rat.
[ Laughter and cheers ]
"Well, they certainly don't have
that in Florida, do they?"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, no, Slurpee Rat.
That's the best
they can do there."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and that was the monologue.
Alright, if you say so.